Let's pray together
here on day three about the sin that breaks the holiness
connection in our lives.
Father, we recognize that you are holy and
pure, and that that holiness you call me to
demands purity. If I am to be holy like you
are holy, I have to be pure like you are pure.
And Lord, like Isaiah, we want to see your holiness.
We want to catch a glimpse of it. We want to realize how
far above us you are. Oh God, let the moral
weight of your glory press down upon our
hearts and minds until it crushes us
down to a place of humility.
Lord, we want to delight in holiness.
We want to see the value and the beauty and the glory of it.
But oh God, when we see the beauty and the purity and the
cleanness of you and your character, it reminds us
that we are not like that.
Oh God, would you change and transform like you did for
Isaiah? We realize, Lord, that the impurity of
our hearts goes deeper than just a few things that we've done wrong.
It goes down to the heart of us and the mouth of us and the habits
and the thinking, and it touches everything that we are.
Oh God, help us to see ourselves. During this 40 days, I
pray for myself and for my prayer partner who's with me here
today. I pray that your holiness would be revealed
to us in new and glorious ways, and that in seeing you,
we would also see ourselves.
I pray that we would not gloss over it, or like James says, walk
away and forget what kind of person we saw, but that we would
trust in you and depend upon you to create in us the
moral clarity and beauty and purity of your
holiness as you did for Isaiah. We pray that you do this in
Jesus' name. Amen. Let's continue in praying and
seeking God together
in your own words.